soon europe / sensations
bonsoir et bienvenue dans un europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de strasbourg est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputé stéphane guillon pourtant
sera notre invité nous évoquerons avec
elle le poids des géants numérique en
europe la maltraitance animale en france
les sévices sont puni de trois ans de
prison et 45000 euros d'amendé nous
verrons comment ça se passe chez nos
voisins mais tout de suite ce jour là le
18 juin 2018 le lancement de discover
the use plus de détails avec mélissa
khelladi europe direct val d'oise
so d'europe ce jour là
le programme discovery où a été lancée
le 18 juin 2018 par la commission
européenne sur recommandation du
parlement européen c'est un programme
qui était totalement à part et depuis
tout récemment depuis fin 2021 il est
totalement intégré au programme erasmus
plus 2021 et 2027 ce programme la
promeut surtout
voilà la mobilité de tout le monde donc
des jeunes les plus éloignés veut
intensifier aussi les mobilité des
apprentis et puis s'inscrit dans une
démarche durable verte et numériques de
plus en plus c'est vraiment les gros
orientations du programme erasmus plus
2021 et 2027 donc qu'est-ce que c'est
discovery ue déjà il ya un petit jeu de
mot discovery ue pour european union
mais yu donc se découvrir soi-même pour
avoir de nouvelles expériences découvrir
l'union européenne grâce au voyage
découverte de nouveaux pays de nouvelles
cultures des nouveaux paysages donc
c'est un programme uniquement pour les
jeunes de 18 ans pile c'est vraiment
l'année de 18 ans et les jeunes qui
s'inscrivent peuvent gagner des pass
intérêts qui leur permettent de voyager
entre une journée et plusieurs mois et
donc tout se passe en ligne c'est un un
formulaire à remplir un questionnaire un
quiz à remplir donc on me voyait on peut
voyager seul ou en groupe il ya beaucoup
de passes qui sont donnés on a commencé
timidement donc là pour la première
édition il ya eu dix huit mille titres
de transport qui ont été données aux
jeunes européens européenne et puis là
pour la dernière dernière édition donc
c'était en automne 2021 il y avait plus
de soixante mille titres de transport
qui auraient été donnés cette fois il ya
une petite exception les jeunes de 19 et
20 ans ont pu également postuler étant
donné que voilà des éditions de 2020 ont
été annulés à cause de la crise
sanitaire donc comment ça se passe pour
pour l'inscription donc il y a deux
sessions par an de candidature donc une
session en automne et une session au
printemps la prom' prochaine session on
n'a pas encore les dates mais il faut
aller rap il faut aller vraiment être en
veille sur le portail européen de la
jeunesse pour avoir la date quand elle
va sortir donc quelles sont les
conditions c'est d'avoir 18 ans
être de nationalité d'un pays membre de
l'union européenne est indiquée correct
ont correctement son numéro de carte
d'identité ou de passeport lors de la
candidature et pour les jeunes en
situation de handicap il est possible et
même s'est mis en place une aide de du
programme discovery ue pour pour voyager
sereinement et pourraient être
accompagnés tout au long de l'expérience
donc les voyages se font essentiellement
en train ça peut bloquer certains jeunes
qui vivent dans les autres mers donc il
est possible aussi de voilà d'avoir des
billets d'avion pour venir directement
dans l'union européenne ou même si on
vient de village très éloignées où il
n'y a pas d'accès au train et pour
organiser son voyage si on a envie de
rencontrer d'autres jeunes qui
participent aussi au programme il ya un
groupe facebook est dédié pour pouvoir
voile organisé des rencontres et créer
du réseau les participants et
participantes du programme sont invités
à communiquer sur leurs expériences en
taguant évidemment discovery ue et puis
lagence erasmus plus et deviennent de
fait comme des ambassadeurs ambassadrice
du programme et peuvent être amenés à
prêt à faire des témoignages auprès
d'autres personnes qui seraient
intéressées fruits en 2021
6950 jeunes ont pu bénéficier de ce
programme dont 8000 72 français donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya un quota par pays
qui est proportionnel au nombre
d'habitants et depuis le début du
programme cent trente mille jeunes ont
pu bénéficier
de discovery you ce qui est quand même
plutôt pas mal et qui permet voilà de
pouvoir c'est un programme totalement
gratuit finalement qui permet de voyager
dans toute l'union européenne donc si
vous voulez plus d'informations
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le
portail repères de la jeunesse où vous
pouvez trouver vraiment toutes les
informations sur les conditions sur les
échéances et sûre sur les règles c'est
le règlement du du programme
sonos robe l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui l'eurodéputé et
stéphane guillon courtin bonjour bonjour
et là vous vous êtes membre du groupe
renault europe ensemble on va évoquer
dans quelques instants le poids des
géants du numérique en europe mais avant
je voudrais qu'on parle du droit à
l'oubli après un traitement contre le
cancer c'est l'un de vos combats aux
côtés d'une autre eurodéputé véronique
trier le noir en france les anciens
malades bénéficient d'un droit à l'oubli
dans un délai de cinq ans un droit qui
n'existent pas partout en europe des
années après leur émission il ya
obligation de déclarer sa maladie auprès
par exemple de sa banque ou de son
assurance quelles sont les conséquences
des actes cela peut avoir les assurances
emprunteur en fait elles considèrent les
anciens malades du cancer comme des
personnes qui potentiellement un risque
aggravé de santé
même des années après leur émission donc
vous imaginez en fait les conséquences
et les difficultés auxquelles ces
anciens malades peuvent être confrontés
c'est la double peine ils lorsqu'ils
souhaitent contracter un prêt pour une
maison créer une entreprise
avoir un projet quelconque les assurant
leur prêtent moins d'argent ouais les
assurances emprunteur pub soit leur
opposer une exclusion d'assurance ou
voir refuser même complètement rejeté
leur demande d'emprunt et dans ces
conditions c'est quand même difficile de
se reconstruire et d'envisager l'avenir
qui est déjà complètement difficile à
concevoir lorsqu'on est malade ou
lorsqu'on a été malade et qu'on est en
rémission c'est la double peine il faut
mettre fin ça justement le parlement a
lancé un plan cancer européen il est
notamment prévu d'étendre ce droit à
l'oubli à l'ensemble de l'union est ce
qu'il ya des freins à cette mesure est
ce qu'il ya des pays qui freinent cette
mesure est qui qui peut justifier
finalement de lutter contre ce genre de
mesures déjà en fait dans la stratégie
sur le plan cancer dont
notre référente et véronique tri et le
noir vous l'avez rappelé on n'a pris
d'engagement d'étendre ce droit à
l'oublié dans toutes les futures
régulation donc en fait il ya ce droit à
l'oubli quai dans la stratégie et toutes
les régulations et donc qui qui qui vont
être votées par le parlement européen
elles doivent contenir c'est notre
engagement le droit à l'oubli et c'est
ce que chez eux notamment en train de
faire dans le la révision de la
directive sur le crédit à la
consommation qui va contenir une de ses
dispositions et donc je tiens à inscrire
dans la loi qui sera formellement
interdit de tenir compte des antécédents
médicaux des personnes qui ont été
touchées par un cancer pour tous les
patients de l'union européenne dix ans
après la fin de leur traitement jusqu'à
cinq ans pour les patients dont le
diagnostic a été posé avant l'âge de 18
ans vous pensez que bon il faut quand
même donner cette période ce délai de
quelques années vous pensez pas que les
malades finalement ils attendent que ben
oui j'ai été malade mais comme d'autres
ont d'autres maladies il faut finalement
oublié tout de suite dans l'instant
bah écoute et oui ce serait peut-être
mieux de l'oublier dans l'instant mais
déjà c'est quand même une c'est quand
même une première pierre qui est posée
et c'est quand même un délai certes qui
nous apparaît comme un étant un délai
raisonnable pour les personnes qui ont
été malades alors effectivement
normalement faudrait le faire dès
maintenant dans un monde idéal mais
c'est déjà un progrès considérable que
d'inscrire dans toutes les régulations
ce droit à l'oubli on a toutes et tous
que ce soit nous mêmes personnellement
dans notre famille dans nos proches des
personnes qui ont qui sont atteints d'un
cancer et c'est complètement injuste
effectivement de leur imposer cette
double peine donc déjà si on peut déjà
s'inscrire par tout ce serait bien de
façon uniforme dans l'union européenne
ce qui n'est pas le cas vous voyez la
france l'a avancé à cinq ans mais nous
bien évidemment on veut que ce soit
uniformément poser dans l'union
européenne et c'est un parcours du
combattant qui qui attend et donc
effectivement et qui attend ces malades
atteints du cancer et donc on veut
vraiment plus leur infliger cette double
peine on peut rappeler que le cancer
c'est la première cause de mortalité en
france la deuxième en europe il existe
de nombreuses inégalités justement dans
les taux de guérison en quelques mots là
aussi une harmonisation des politiques à
avoir au niveau de la lutte cette fois
ci au compte le cancer comment est ce
que on peut harmoniser cette lutte et
même la prise en charge finalement mais
en fait il faut harmoniser les deux
c'est en mutualisant les connaissances
et les moyens que l'on parviendra à
lutter contre le cancer et à proposer
les meilleurs coups possibles aux
européens d'abord
sur le volet de la prévention et je
salue ce que ce que porte véronique très
le noir ma collègue parce que les études
scientifiques l'attestent 40% des
cancers pourraient être évités par des
mesures de prévention or là il ya une
extrême hétérogénéité
en termes de prévention dans les
différents états membres à l'intérieur
même des états membres notamment si on
prend la france est bien en fonction de
là où vous vivez et en fonction du
milieu social dans lequel vous êtes il
ya véritablement des différentiels plan
cancer européen qu'on a adopté en
février dernier au parlement européen il
met l'accent justement sur la prévention
tant au niveau national qu'au niveau
européen ils portent par exemple un
objectif fort parvenir à une génération
sans tabac en europe d'ici 2040 ça c'est
sur le volet prévention mais parler du
volet prise en charge et on sait que
dans certains états membres les patients
recouvre
rapidement d'autres beaucoup moins la
santé grâce à des soins parce que
certains rencontrent des difficultés
d'accès aux soins les européens des pays
du nord et des pays de l'est bénéficient
pas toujours d'un système de santé
solide ils sont pas égaux face à la
maladie et avec le plan cancer on
voudrait vraiment rectifier ces
inégalités en renforçant la coopération
également entre les états membres en
favorisant la mobilité des patients et
en favorisant la mobilité des médecins
des oncologues qui sont peut-être plus
expérimentés sur certains états et qui
pourrait donc être plus facilement
mobile dans d'autres états est-ce que la
santé en train de devenir une compétence
européenne
eh bien elle recommencer et bien
effective à la crise sanitaire a été un
révélateur a été un déclencheur de plus
d'europe et mieux d'europe en matière de
santé et faire en sorte qu effectivement
la compétence santé soit une compétence
européenne et on voit notamment beaucoup
d'états pour lesquels la compétence en
tête et régionales l'espagne et l'italie
demandé à ce que au delà de la
centralisation
uniformisation nationale effectivement
elles le soient mieux prises en compte
au niveau européen et donc c'est
vraiment une meilleure gestion
européenne de façon générale de
prévention de réaction au risque le coc
vide de façon urgente et puis ensuite de
suivi effectivement des différentes et
pour les malades et des différentes
maladies et pathologies alors on va
s'intéresser maintenant aux géants du
numérique vous êtes vice président de la
commission des affaires économiques et
monétaires au parlement l'un des enjeux
de la présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne s'est notamment
l'encadrement des activités économiques
des grandes plateformes du numérique
alors est-ce que déjà vous pouvez nous
expliquer dans quel but il faut encadrer
ces grandes plateformes parce que ses
protégés peut-être déjà l'économie
européenne et les entreprises
européennes là avant d'encadrer ces deux
éviter que le far west ne règne plus
donc c'est véritablement d'assurer les
mêmes chances pour toutes les
entreprises on voit que on a d'un côté
une poignée d'entreprises les gars
femmes les gammes am les géants de la
tech qui ont développé des réseaux
tentaculaires à tel point qu'elles sont
ultra dominante ultra puissante et
qu'elles sont capables d'imposer leurs
propres règles leurs propres lois aux
petites entreprises qui souhaitent
pénétrer les marchés du numérique et ça
ça va pas parce que la concurrence est
une obligation en dehors des du marché
numérique c'est à dire hors ligne et
donc il doit y avoir des règles en ligne
et c'est les mêmes chances également de
proposer des produits et des services
aux consommateurs et d'accéder au marché
pouvoir pour les petites entreprises à
accéder au marché innover donc le dma
'digital markets act out sur les marchés
numériques pour la première fois il est
inédit et historique parce que il va
imposer des règles pour assurer une
équité justement entre les entreprises
sur ces marchés numériques et faire en
sorte que et bien les petites
entreprises vous avez parié dako vide
tout à l'heure qui vont de plus en plus
sur ses marchés du numérique pour
développer leur chiffre d'affaires et
leur business puissent accéder de façon
équitable à ces marchés sans dépendre de
ces poignée d'entreprises qui vont leur
imposer soit des obligations
complètement exorbitantes par exemple
des commissions pour être sur les plates
formes qui vont être très cher
bien les sortir des marchés quand elles
le souhaitent une autre question ce qui
est aussi d'interdire par exemple donc
vous le disais la publicité ciblée mais
il ya aussi la publicité ciblée qui
disent les mineurs parce que quand on
quand on est mineur on ne sait pas
forcément à quoi on a affaire quand on
est sûr sur internet ces publicités
ciblées elles utilisent les données
sensibles comme des orientations
politiques d'orientation sexuelle des
caractères et ethniques vous pensez que
il faut lutter aussi pour qu'on soit
tous égaux face au traitement de ces
grosses grosses sociétés alors vous
parlez là est effectivement du contenu
du contenu des de ce qu'on a sur
internet du contenu et des produits
d'ailleurs et de ce que véhiculent ces
plateformes ça c'est un autre acte c'est
un autre règlement qui s'appelle au
digital services et à claques sur les
services numériques qui est en cours la
de discussion qu'on aimerait bien
également pouvoir
finaliser d'ici la fin de la présidence
française de l'union européenne et qui
bien évidemment vise à uniformiser les
règles qui sont destinées à réguler les
contenus les contenus haineux
effectivement les publicités destinées
aux mineurs et faire en sorte qu'on ait
le consentement
appuyé renforcer notamment du
consommateur du lecteur va pas mettre
des sanctions en place bien sûr c'est
une sanction qui sont qui sont prévues
et qui sont très importantes alors elles
sont discutés sur le ds ça c'est donc
sur le service numérique sur les
contenus dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
et les produits qui sont mis en ligne
c'est en discussion en revanche
s'agissant du dma il ya des sanctions
très importantes qui vont être infligée
aux gatekeeper c'est contrôleur d'accès
ces géants de la tech qui ne
respecteraient pas les obligations ou
interdictions qui leur seront faites qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à 10% du chiffre
d'affaires mondial ii
groupes concernés ou bien en cas de
récidive c'est à dire que si elle ne se
conforme pas ça pourrait aller jusqu'à
20% du chiffre d'affaires voire
éventuellement
l'interdiction d'acquérir une entreprise
qui une petite entreprise que le géant
projetterait de 2,2 de finaliser très
bien merci beaucoup d'être à lyon
content d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés et
membre du groupe renault c'est ça merci
beaucoup hugo
zone europe chez nos voisins
et chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
c'est notre rubrique en partenariat avec
a choisi l'institut des hautes études de
journalisme de montpellier cette semaine
la maltraitance animale avec olivier
payet alors chez nous en france la
maltraitance animale et c'est drôlement
puni par la loi une personne qui exerce
publiquement ou non un acte sexuel ou
qui commet tout acte de cruauté envers
un animal domestique apprivoisé ou en
captivité encourt jusqu'à deux ans de
prison et 30 millions euros damende
depuis le jeudi 18 novembre la loi sur
la maltraitance animale est entrée en
vigueur avec le durcissement des peines
comme par exemple l'interdiction
d'animaux sauvages dans les cirques un
passe-droit justifiant de si oui ou non
on est apte à être posséder un animal
domestique
mais encore là et asie de l'interdiction
de vendre des châteaux des chiens
directement en animalerie et du côté de
nos voisins européens comment est elle
punit en allemagne une pratique barbare
avec sur le point de disparaître c'est
du broyage de plus à mal en effet cette
méthode très critiquée par les
défenseurs de la condition animale
condamne chaque année la bataille de
plus de 45 millions de poussins en
revanche du côté de l'espagne la
situation est beaucoup plus alarmante et
notamment l'abattage de la et l'abandon
de milliers de livres et de lévriers
chaque année une condition qu'ils ne
risquent pas de s'arranger à d'après
l'inaction du gouvernement espagnol un
déséquilibre pour la condition animale
qui se creuse au sein des pays européens
soon europe
les superstitions en europe avec kevin
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine
aux hirondelles
parler de l'hirondelle
on dit qu'une hirondelle ne fait pas le
printemps
et il y à pas mal de superstition
toujours hérité du monde paysan sur ces
hirondelles
donc quand une hirondelle arrive et va
chercher à nicher
soul de votre maison c'est un porte
bonheur assuré pour toute l'année donc
on ne devrait pas chercher à faire
tomber le nid la porte malheur pourquoi
les gens cherchent à se débarrasser d'un
nid d'hirondelle c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de chutes au sol c'est très fan alors si
on veut une jolie terrasse ou une belle
entrée l'hirondelle va gêner un petit
peu et il vaudrait mieux tolérés
l'hirondelle et les chiens qui porte
bonheur plutôt que de la virée la même
hirondelles si elle vient volts et
autour de quelqu'un c'est ainsi sa passe
est un jour
c'est une ancienne superstition
peut-être pas très facile à respecter
si on veut être sûrs d'être aimée il
faudrait aller déposer un anneau dans le
nid de l'hirondelle le laisser neuf
jours dans ce lit aller le récupérer et
à partir de là on va l'offrir et bas à
l'être aimé il faut laisser le chameau
le charme agir bien sûr et dernier
dernière chose à ne pas faire si on veut
si on a fait tomber le nid de
l'hirondelle c'est de balayer parce que
en balayant on emporte aussi
le porte-bonheur qui étaient là
soon europe voyage
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
voyager dans l'assiette cette semaine un
dessert italien le tiramisu du chef
julien seri alors la recette est très
simple on va mettre le jaune d'oeuf dans
la cuve du batteur
le sucre
et on va battre très très fort où m le
robot pâtissier au maximum
et on le laisse travailler
[Applaudissements]
donc l'objectif c'est de faire fondre le
sucre
pour qu'on voit plus du tout la
cristallisation du sucre à ce moment là
on va pouvoir ajouter le mascarpone en
trois fois
hop là
et même opération
[Applaudissements]
quand on a un mélange bien homogène up
en incorpore
la deuxième partie du mascarpone
et c'est parti pour la deuxième étape
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on commence à avoir un bel aspect une
belle crème et on vient ajouter le reste
du mascarpone
[Applaudissements]
et
voilà c'est fini
on y va pour le montage alors on va
commencer par mettre une première couche
de crème dans le fond du contenant
comme ça
un biscuit qu'on va imbibé très
rapidement dans un café très corsé avec
marsala ou du rhum l'alcool que vous
préférez
la même chose pour la deuxième couche
une autre couche de biscuits imbibés
toujours très rapidement et on va
terminer en faisant un joli dom
de crem
assez généreux sur le dessus
alors la petite touche sur notre
tiramisu c'est un caramel au beurre salé
maison un salidou
dans lequel on a mis de la fève de tonka
et on va terminer
avec un peu de gourmandise est croquant
les brisures de spéculoos
et voilà un tiramisu breton
sous drop
les superstitions en europe avec evelyne
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine au
miroir vallée du miroir à pas mal de
phrases
et de superstitions liées au miroir
on va dire que briser un miroir c'est
sept ans de malheur ça se vit encore
pourquoi le miroir porte malheur parce
que le miroir quelque part on s'y voit
donc s'il reflète son âme et sa personne
et une âme en morceaux et pas souhaité
mais comme habituellement dans les
quatre porte malheur on va trouver des
gestes ou des paroles à faire pour
contrer ce mauvais présage il y en a une
qui consiste à ramasser tous les
morceaux du miroir et chercher une
rivière aller dans le sens de la du sud
est en marche le long de la rivière et
dès qu'on peut on se débarrasse des
morceaux de vos miroirs brisés et là le
mauvais sort et conjurer on peut aussi
elle est enterrée ces morceaux de
miroirs brisés on peut encore les
enterrer donc quelque part on suit
disparaître mauvais sort
il ne faut jamais se regarder dans dans
indique la de miroirs brisés ça porte
malheur il y a aussi une tradition qui
respecte et dans pas mal de
quand quelqu'un décède dans la maison
la tradition veut que l'on
voile les miroirs la crêpe pas mais on
voit le miroir parce qu'on pense que le
corps du défunt quand il va s'en aller
pour être emporté l'âme des vivants de
la maison
c'est très important de voile et le
miroir zone europe s'est terminée merci
aux équipes techniques du parlement
européen de strasbourg vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en podcast
audio et vidéo sur notre site et notre
application radio sensations et aussi
sur tv soixante dix huit rendez vous la
semaine prochaine bonne soirée
[Musique]
soon robe sûr sensation
en europe
[Musique]